so there was this competing conference
to cpac over the weekend called afpak
the america first yeah the america first
political action conference
it is a white nationalist far-right
conference
overtly so you could say well isn't cpac
sort of that cpac is
what's crazy is cpac is now a
radicalized version of what republicans
used to be
afpak is a radicalized cpac and uh there
were a whole bunch of different white
nationalist extremists at the rally
and her conference and marjorie taylor
green
was a headline speaker at the event and
she was then rightly criticizing you
went to what is almost an out and out
nazi event it's a white nationalist
event these are some of the absolute
worst people right now
and she claims ignorance to all of it so
let's take a look she said i was there
because i want to speak to young people
let's listen but i'm glad to talk to you
about this i do not know nick fuentes
i've never heard him speak i've never
seen a video i don't know what his views
are so i'm not blind with anything that
may be controversial what i can tell you
is i went to his event last night to
address his very large following because
that is a young it's a very young
following and it's a generation i'm
extremely concerned about it's a white
nation excuse me i'll tell you exactly
why i went i went to talk to them about
america's first policies and i talked to
them about what it's interesting she
says she doesn't know who nick fuentes
is and she doesn't know anything about
the white nationalist leanings of he and
the group
but she knows that these are young
people and that there's a bunch of them
and that they care about america first
and for for having no idea who these
people were
you seem to know a lot about it i spoke
here knowing it was a large group of
young people engaged in america first
policy controversies white nationalism i
don't know anything about that so i just
wanted to speak to them to give them my
america first ideas absurd she then put
out a written statement
where she said i mean look at that look
at this
self-victimization the pharisees in the
republican party may attack me for being
willing to break barriers what what what
a martyr huh and speak to a lost
generation of young people who were
desperate for love and leadership but i
won't abandon these young men and women
because i believe we need to do better
by them i won't cancel others if the
conservative in the conservative
movement even if i find some of their
statements tasteless marge
it's a white nationalist event
i encourage them to seek wisdom and
apologize to those who have been hurt by
their words or as i've had to do our
faith calls for charity and forgiveness
and then she just goes completely insane
i'll keep fighting against identity
politics and marxism
what marxism are you fighting against
i'll keep speaking out and speaking up
our nation is only capable of protecting
sovereignty and then um
uh pulling out this insane statement the
atheist media demands no disavow from
left-wing politicians who hang out with
jihadis and abortionists but they demand
immediate disavowals of any republican
willing to speak to 1200 people gathered
to declare that christ is king and brand
them in headlines exclusively by their
sins just as a little sampling of what
there was at this affac event
just before bringing on marjorie taylor
greene
there was uh nick fuentes saying that
their secret sauce is young white men
and then everybody started chanting
putin putin
and you want to know the secret
uh to borrow a phrase from a friend of
mine our secret sauce here it's these
young
white men
that's what we call the secret
ingredient america and the world has
forgotten about them but not us
i don't think anybody's forgotten about
young white men say about
america they say
diversity is our strength you know and i
look at china and i look at russia who
can we give a round of applause for
russia
yes
absolutely absolutely yeah so then
marjorie taylor green spoke and uh the
rest is sort of history these are really
dangerous movements and there's levels
right there's concentric circles it's
like okay you've got the entire right
wing like all right well that's a pretty
big range you've got absolute lunatic
murderous extremists and you've got
people where
i disagree with them about what the top
tax rate should be okay all right but
then you've got to find within that
you've got
the trumps the trumpians
and then you've got the cpac trumpians
and then you've got people like marjorie
taylor green
and then you've got so there's these
concentric circles and unfortunately it
can all spread outward and infect the
entire movement and that's how you end
up with more than half believing joe
biden didn't really win the 2020
election
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video